[Music]
dude today by the way guys you guys been
it's been fun going great like every
week we're just slowly just building the
group we're like a basketball team yeah
yeah like now we're doing no-look passes
and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying it's
also because we like ryan some of the
other hosts are [ __ ] dicks dicks
who's our least favorite like guest
least favorite guest let's go come on
the moment everybody's like
three two
that little sip gave me a head change
already hell yeah let's go show
everybody hold on people don't know
joe's drinking today guys
joe when's the last time you drink a
good thing we had a good crypto day
let's [ __ ] let's go good one
anybody a lord of the rings fan i'm sure
none of you are i watched it but i don't
know if i'm a fan i love lord of the
rings [ __ ] yeah dude name one
[ __ ] character other than frodo
dominos
he's the guy that says you should not
pass yep fax golem yeah
yeah gollum stadamire stop saying truths
real quick just give me a minute to just
dive deep in the [ __ ] idiocracy gone
free that's cool gone free no elliott
those are elliot reynolds bob welch
i love bob wilshere
you don't know what you're talking about
give me one real answer wait do you
actually none of those are real
characters those are all characters dude
gollum
king arthur he's the guy with the bow
and arrow roy lavin roy lavin fourth
haven's real no no let me school bart do
you know who the nozzles are do you know
what their individual names are
the you know the center my brother's a
huge lawyer i love this right now the
center of the pack is bob welsh
stupid
yeah they all have really normal
literally like they really have names
bob welsh tim johnson
and elliott ghoul
why are they all modern
they're stuck traders dumbass
i just remembered deadly shrimp
and thinking this is a [ __ ] long
movie and it's just them walking bro it
was a long long i enjoyed it i liked i
liked the first one it was like gopro
camping wait what what wait what that's
right is that rod stewart this is
actually bob that's bob it's bob welch
see yeah he's one of the nazi's the head
writer bro he's one of the style members
he's one of the star of mine first of
all
stop
does anybody at least know what orcs are
yeah yeah
okay what what but you know what they're
the troll looking things he's a tattoo
artist you already played warcraft you
know what an orc is yeah i mean i
appreciate your like level-headedness i
watched the will smith movie yeah which
the will smith movie he's he's partners
with the orc yeah he's a cop he's a cop
oh that's what or i don't know
oh yeah bright or something bright blue
that was a terrible movie why did they
do that
it was such a better idea for a movie
than a movie yeah um yeah it was like
yeah it was like like a snl skit it
didn't need to be that long
five minutes that's it should have been
scheduled the point is the orcs are the
uh they're like the putties of [ __ ]
power rangers dude i know dude or i know
who orcs
they die whatever they the antagonist
in a multitude form of uh massive
warfare right i thought you were a geek
and you're really into this stuff i do
like it but i haven't like don't hide it
here i've been watching it and that's
the bar dude i like laura what do you
guys have to do with anything yeah what
what is that he's not gonna beat you up
man dude i think bart's the only one
that don't know
i do
know harry potter ghibli yeah what's the
sword called hey i'm not that far away i
watched it but i don't know all i'm
saying is bart's like three decades
behind us no i watched all of them but
my memory does not serve me that's okay
that's but you still know [ __ ] needle
you still know what an orchid you know
gollum is you know you know things i
don't know okay that's not the point
it's not about ourselves that's game of
thrones it's about putties it's about
all right how an orc
in the lord of the rings was
styled right to made to look like tim
welsh harvey weinstein shut the [ __ ] up
according to one of the stars in the
movie and this recently came out oh are
they doing that for brownie points
though or were they like they
was this like a joke that turned into
like oh yeah now we could [ __ ] on him
because he's in trouble is this like jk
rowling saying everyone was bi in harry
potter
yeah was it merlin
i guess that's comparable gandalf right
gandalf
no
no no but dumbledore she was saying
dumbledore was born
that [ __ ] is funny to imagine jk rowling
doing a tweet all right gandalf's now bi
but exactly she didn't write it she just
says later on how gay and how big they
are everyone just goes with it oh she
she did write it really but you once
annoying though is like they don't
really ever mention it in the books or
the movies if you read the books you had
to read between the lines
you know what's funny is that's kind of
what's going on right now with superman
have you guys seen this oh yeah
yeah boyfriend superman's bi now yeah he
has a japanese boyfriend
son but exactly so that's what people
are missing everyone's just going well
do you know superman's biosphere they're
just saying superman that's not what
they're say
that's not what dc is doing they're
saying no superman's kid is yeah so it's
different
wait it's not just superman's body
superman had a kid with lowest lanes
well you know what i i get my news from
neck shark instagram
so all i saw was uh
it just said superman gay but see at
least they're saying like hey this is
like
this iteration of the character and it's
not the same as the old iteration that's
the you created a character that is this
modern day yeah fly character that's
great but this [ __ ] i know the whole
time i was with the movement guys check
it out everyone's bi yeah [ __ ] off man
such pantry [ __ ] marketing yeah
super pandaria but harvey weinstein is
ugly as [ __ ] though he is kind of
he looks like a real villain he does i
heard he got a [ __ ] up dick too really
i heard he barely got a dick at all
that's yeah like it's deformed guy with
a with a [ __ ] up dick he looked like
he melted or something no he looked like
he milked it he doesn't like his mouth
he looks like a real villain dude he's a
real cut this guy didn't he
was very cut behavior he thinks he did
how do you define cuck again
he like watched people [ __ ] his wife oh
i thought it was a guy who [ __ ] gwen
paltrow before he [ __ ] with paltrow he
did really i just
that's what that translates to yes
they say uh they say he looks like this
character in the lord of the rings oh
yeah for sure gotham yes he does
let me go ahead and uh really quickly go
back to uh
yo imagine being a [ __ ] actress and
that is the final boss level that you
have to [ __ ] in order to like
that's that's rough man we're not you
mean this guy or not that's probably
what it feels like
that yeah that probably is probably what
it feels like you get to that level and
then and it's kind of like who wants to
be a millionaire right and it's like
deal or no deal and all that [ __ ] and
then you're sitting there and you're
just like [ __ ] what should i do harvey
when she's in jail right now yeah
is he wait i think he's awaiting trial
but yes
which is also why this uh actor this
star was more willing to come out who
said it information who do you think
viggo mortensen nope lego lost nope
orlando
blues lando jones i know what that was
going on okay i love that you tried to
come in what's the guy samwise ganji
yeah one guy from goonies what's his
name what's his real name elijah
goonfield no no no no the other cat
field
the one that played sloth sam
in the movie i'm just saying
elijah wood was
angelina gooney
who was just in the stranger with him
isn't it sam is his name sam
the cop the older dude
the guy who gets eaten in the city got
eaten big time he's married to one on a
writer
and he was quite the meal
or who's that daniel boone
elliot ghoul
elliott gould elliott goon oh my god
anyway so yeah it was actually elijah
wood oh there's one in an interview
uh who said this and he said the actor
who played frodo baggins in the peter
jackson adaptation spoke out on dax
shepard's armchair expert podcast and
said that the disgraced movie mogul was
the inspiration for the face of one of
the orcs and and it's not a confirmation
that uh this character this orc called
gothmog the lieutenant
wow
it's not a confirmation but that's the
fan speculation they're assuming that
it's that they think that's the one
they're talking about because at the end
of the day when you look at harvey
weinstein you look at this dude you're
kind of like oh i see it that's true can
we not be biased for a second and just
pull up other orcs so that we can get an
idea because you know what is like a
ratemypoo.com but with orcs harvey
weinstein did he play like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the show entourage he played
himself wasn't he in that show
didn't he play a disgrace [ __ ] who
like
manipulated women he was a total [ __ ]
like douchebag on the show really i
think he played i could be completely
mistaken but from why i remember huh
elijah
uh said on my first name basis
elijah me and elijah the widow
he revealed that the mask was modeled
around weinstein's face as a [ __ ] you
after he would uh he had upset some of
the cast and crew oh
right so uh speaking to dax elijah said
he had seen these orc masks and one of
the orc masks
uh and i remember vividly was designed
to look like harvey weinstein and it was
sort of a [ __ ] you which i think is okay
to talk about now that the guys now that
the guy is [ __ ] incarcerated [ __ ] him
literally literally elijah wood is just
did miramax do this movie uh it was uh
weinstein's company miramax originally
owned the rights of the lord of the
rings films and reportedly made life
difficult elijah was shooting shooting
shots bro [ __ ] harvey weinstein a
little bit yeah they took the needle to
him huh yeah yeah i think that's game of
thrones isn't it the name of the sword
the needle is the is the uh the needle
is yeah the frodo the frodo sword sting
is in lord of the rings needle is arya
stars that's what it is yeah needle is
the sword from that fertile
my brother's a big fan i'm telling him
what and sting is bob welsh he had a
fiddle too
who the [ __ ] is bob well
he's gandalf dude
he's bisexual bro
well
he's the bisexual nas ghoul dude
were you even listening official leader
of the nos glory she's at the head of
the triangle the nozzles were the the
guys with the hoods yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the writers bro yeah the
writers poisoned the hood who the [ __ ]
is bob
they were all bisexuals